we talked about 11 mass shootings in the
United States over the weekend more than
300 total shootings
those are the real numbers 11 mass
shootings 300 total shootings and much
of what we got from the gun people as I
call them after the Allen Texas shooting
left eight dead seven injured at a mall
much of it was the same do-nothing
adject trash that we've been looking at
for decades but we heard from an
interesting guy a witness of the mall
shooting his name is Stephen spanauer
and one of the things that he said was
I'm an ex-cop
I'm an ex-military officer I'm a gun
person I love guns he loves his guns
but he said it wasn't Mental Health that
killed these people it was an automatic
rifle with bullets this guy presenting
some moral Clarity on this as a gun
lover Okay let's listen I don't know
what the gunman's problem was I don't
know his motive but it wasn't mental
health that killed his people it was an
automatic rifle with bullets that's to
kill him I'm a gun lover I have guns I'm
a former police officer I'm a former
Army officer but these m4s in AR-15s
they've got to get off the streets or
this is going to keep happening and
we've got to stop that at some point it
could be you it could be your family
member I never imagined it would be me I
never imagined it would happen in my
community but it did and we got to stop
this type of Carnage and all the
politicians in the world and make
statements they're going to offer
prayers and condolences
won't bring these people back right we
need some action in our legislatures at
the federal and state level for better
gun control I'm saying that as someone
who loves guns who can argue with that
and you know what this isn't that rare
of a view among the progressive gun
owners I know so many people my age
older younger progressives who own guns
and have this exact same view and to be
perfectly Frank much of their gun
ownership this guy loves guns okay good
for him but he has the clarity to say
we've got to do something about the guns
I have some friends who love guns and
collect and all this stuff and they are
completely fine saying it should be
really strict I'm willing to do whatever
I need to do I'll get the safe I'll get
the insurance I'll get the required I'll
get a mental health eval not that these
things are required but they're willing
to do them if everybody subjected them
we'll do the mental health eval I'll do
uh liability insurance re-licensing eye
exam right it's got to be at least as
difficult as getting and maintaining a
car and a license on the road uh but
some of my Progressive gun owning
friends just realize that they don't
want only the right Wingers having the
guns and that that becomes a race to the
bottom arguably even though I sympathize
with that and I understand it so we need
something to change that most of us
would agree with although there are some
on the right who actually say we don't
need anything to change other than
buying people buying more guns okay well
they're pretty sick it's going to be
hard to talk to them but we have a list
of very low hanging fruit that the
country by and large agrees with we
looked at the poll last week uh
background checks in all cases at the
top of the list uh waiting periods
Banning some guns etc etc we can we know
some of the things that the country
agrees with but there's too much money
raised there's too much NRA blood money
which is effectively what it is doled
out to elected officials and
unfortunately listen I don't want to say
nothing will ever change that's a
defeatist attitude we've seen just about
every scenario teed up where you should
be able to knock one out of the park
easily and and achieve some change after
Sandy Hook comes to mind and yet nothing
or almost nothing happens so good for
Steve spanauer for saying what he said
gun lover but it wasn't mental health it
was the guns that did this meanwhile
there are still Republicans saying all
we need is thoughts and prayers let's
look at that next when there's a
non-fiction book I just don't have the
time to read having a summary of the
book is really valuable several
different platforms out there will
summarize books I've tried them all
short form is by far the most impressive
one and it goes Way Beyond what other
platforms do our sponsor short form not
only will Summarize the book covering
all of the key ideas short form also
provides analysis and commentary that
contextualizes the book comparing it to
what other books say about the same
topic and you can read or listen to the
entire thing in one sitting for instance
the book dark money by Jane Mayer about
how wealthy Republicans are covertly
influencing American politics short form
clearly and concisely sums up the book's
most important takeaways but it also
gives you a ton of other crucial
background about lobbying libertarianism
and that helps you really understand how
does the book fit into the broader topic
of conservative money in politics that's
why I love short form short form has
every genre politics business Tech
biographies and my audience can try
short form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription at Short form.com Pacman
the link is down below